can we talk a little bit about
evil sure
i haven't actually talked to you about
this topic
and it's been sitting on my mind mostly
because
everybody at mit is quiet about it
which is jeffrey epstein
i didn't get a chance to experience what
mit was like at the time when jeffrey
epstein was part of this
but it's i'd love to try to understand
how evil was allowed to flourish
in in a place that i love
whether you think
maybe let me ask the question this way
was it
the man evil or was the system
evil or is evil too strong a word
because what i see is the presence
of of this particular human being
in the eyes of many destroyed
the reputations of many really strong
scientists and also
weaken the ability
like weaken the institution of mit by
making everybody quiet like almost
making them unable to say anything
interesting or difficult
yeah and what what is that
and what am i supposed to uh we don't
know
why is everyone quiet about jeffrey we
don't no
we don't know obviously i want to scream
about it too
right and i probably have said too much
about jeffrey epstein
look something horrible happened i don't
know what it is
but something horrible happened and
you know at the one thing that okay
let's just do this the first thing i
need to do is i need to get rid of this
woke crap about power differentials
okay in general
you can talk about hypergamy and power
differentials
are russell conjugates of the same
concept
just the way particular proportions and
symmetries
are mathematically provable to be
attractive
in females to males
male attractiveness is largely
determined by
male competence and ability to amass
power and success and all these sorts of
things
the relationship between consenting
adults
is quite frankly not something i want to
sort out
the relationship between the sexuality
of adults
and minors and particularly
you know there's the the the
1718 issue
that's very different than 1213.
we're talking about really sick
depravity
with respect to what it appears that
jeffrey epstein was involved in
at some level i believe this story is
super complicated
in part because i think one thing
jeffrey epstein was doing
was providing money encouragement
and support to scientists another thing
he was doing i believe was giving tax
advice
to very rich people i believe another
thing he was doing
was hooking
very wealthy people up with young adult
females another thing he was doing
i think was doing stuff with children
that
will curl your toes
so between so there's an entire spectrum
of different stuff
and at the moment nobody can pull apart
or deconflate
anything because the woke thing comes
over it and says
you know i think it's disgusting that uh
you know a 43 year old billionaire would
be partying with a 23 year old
right yeah okay yeah i don't want to
adjudicate that
i'm worried about 12 and 14 year olds
that we're not talking about but i
mostly
i don't think mit was deep into
pedophilia
my guess is that that did not happen i
don't think that the scientists
were the targets of the really sick
depraved stuff
it's my guess my my guess is is that
what you're looking at was a government
construct
it may have been our government it may
have been a joint government project
maybe somebody else's government
i don't know i believe that in part
we don't really understand robert
maxwell
sorry who's robert maxwell gillane
gillen aswell's father
was very active in scientific publishing
i don't know where peer review came from
i would love to run down the
relationship between peer review and
robert maxwell i would love to run down
the
missing fortune of robert maxwell and
mysterious fortune of jeffrey epstein
because i don't think jeffrey epstein
ever ran a hedge fund
i don't think he was a money advisor the
way people claimed
so there's two things i want to talk
about so one
is the shallow conversations of woke
identity politics that you're referring
to
seems to be removing everyone's ability
no everyone willingness one of the
things to talk about like
what the hell is this person and how is
he allowed
more most importantly to how do
we prevent it in the future and from the
individual perspective the question for
me
is the same question i ask about 1930s
nazi germany i've been reading way too
much probably
or not enough about that period
currently is if i was
in germany at that time what is the
heroic action to take
when i think about mit with jeffrey
epstein what is the heroic action to
take we're not talking about virtue
signaling i wouldn't
know what to do i would like to know
what you're up against lex
you're not hearing me the problem here
is
what was jeffrey epstein well that
question
might be the heroic action to take
that's what i'm trying to say i'm just
trying to get my first question
you have to map the silence with jeffrey
epstein what you're describing
is a map of the silence at mit
yeah well is there a map of the silence
in washington state around jeffrey
epstein
the bay area new york city the amount of
silence around jeffrey epstein should be
telling you everything
the number of dogs that don't bark is
like nothing we've ever seen
you're exactly correct but i want to
know what is it telling us
because what it's telling me is not some
kind of conspiracy
but more a disappointing
weakness not some kind of conspiracy
it's not some kind of conspiracy but
you've got to be kidding me
no you're so you're so afraid of saying
the word conspiracy that you don't think
it's a conspiracy
i personally i just think it's people
who i thought were my heroes
just being weak no
be of good cheer sir a cheer
be of good cheer of good cheer yeah you
think that there is a conspiracy
i think there is a conspiracy
that'd be a very impressive one that's
the scale of it
i i tend to believe that large scale
can only be an emergent phenomena really
i find this so fascinating yeah because
i always see you as like a
logic logic and love drive your drive
your soul
you're very logical you're relentless
you've got a lot of love in your heart
i believe that if you would review the
video where is it from dubai or abu
dhabi
of the mysterious hit on the hotel guest
you ever seen this thing yeah oh what
happened it's the assassination
in 2010 10 years ago of
mahmoud al mabu something like that
in dubai where i believe
26 separate individuals
on multiple teams are shown converging
coming in from all over the world
on false passports pretending to be
tennis
players or you know business people or
vacationers
and all of these teams have different
functions
and they murder this guy in his in his
hotel room
and the dubai i guess chief of police
security officer was so uh
angered that he put together this
amazing video that says
we can completely detail what you did we
caught you on closed circuit tv
we don't know exactly who you are
because your disguises and your false
passports
but yeah 26 people converged to kill one
no i don't believe you i don't believe
after cointelpro
an operation paperclip and uh
operation mockingbird uh
i don't know whether i should even bring
up rex84
to not believe in conspiracies is an
idiocy
so you you have a sense that uh
evil can be as competent or more
competent
first of all when evil wants to operate
at scale it needs to make sure that
people don't try to figure out evil
when evil operates at scale yes from
first principles you have to realize
that evil
must not want it investigated that's
correct
the most efficient way
to keep yourself from being investigated
if you are a an
evil institutional player who needs to
do this repeatedly
is to invest in a world in which no one
can afford
to say the word conspiracy you will
notice that there is a
special radioactivity around the word
conspiracy
we have provable conspiracies we have
admitted to conspiracies
you have been invited to conspiracies
there is no shortage conspiracies are
everywhere
some of them are mundane some of them
are like price fixing cartels
you know or trade groups are generally
speaking conspiracies
so the first thing you have to realize
is that all of us
are under a in a mimetic complex where
you can be taken off the chess board by
saying conspiracy theorists
get done it's a one it's like a one-line
proof we don't have to listen to lex
he said he was a conspiracy theorist on
this show okay
that is partially distorting our
conversation if you want to ask me about
jeffrey epstein you have to agree with
me
that that is a logical description of
what you would have to have
if you wanted to commit conspiracies is
that you have to make sure that people
are dissuaded from investigating yes
okay but it's a very it's a
fascinatingly difficult
idea then because the world with
conspiracy theories in the world without
conspiracy theories
to the sh to the shallow glance looks
the same well
my point there is responsible conspiracy
theorizing where you look at the history
of
unearthed conspiracies and just like you
would with any other topic just think
about how different the rules in your
mind are
for conspiracy theorizing versus x
theorizing where x can be anything
right it's like if i say to you um
i can say the statement that average
weight
is not the same between widely separated
populations
you'd say yeah i'd say average height is
not the same between widely separated
populations
you'd say yeah then i say in fact no
continuous variable
that has that shows variation should be
expected to be identical between widely
separated of course eric
like iq whoa whoa hold on
right so we have a violent reaction to
specific topics
so the first thing i want to do is just
to notice
that conspiracy has that built into
everyone's mind
that's really important to state yeah
that's it's very interesting
at that and as a prerequisite as you're
saying that would be the first step if
you wanted to uh
pull off a conspiracy in a competent way
that's you would have to first convince
the world i just watched the film 1971
about my favorite conspiracy of all time
i highly recommend it 1971 well the film
is entitled 1971
and it's about the citizens committee to
investigate the fbi
which was run by a student of murray
gelman
a physicist and broke into fbi offices
in pennsylvania
to steal files which allowed freedom of
information requests that discovered a
huge conspiracy it was a conspiracy that
unearthed a conspiracy inside the
federal government
a double conspiracy story
which launched multiple conspiracies i
think that the problem with modern
americans is that they are so
timid that they don't even learn about
the history of conspiracies that we have
absolutely proven so with that done
jeff epstein in my opinion represented
somebody's [ __ ]
construction i don't know scary to think
about
yeah well what part of the story isn't
scary
i in part did something which i i
imagine may get me destroyed
because i was more worried about being
destroyed by somebody else i had a
conversation with
around jeff epstein right so i'm just
trying to like
get let it be known that i don't know
anything more than i've already said
now your friends at mit yeah
their problem is is that jeff epstein
showed up
as the only person capable of continuing
u.s scientific tradition
you see the u.s scientific tradition
is a little bit like the russian it's
it's combative
okay and we're a free society and we act
like a free society we're a rich society
and we research like we're a rich
society that is historically and then
came the 1970s
and william proxmyer and the golden
fleece awards and the idea that we have
to
we're paying too much and these are
welfare queens and lab coats and blah
blah blah blah
we need more transparency more oversight
everything went to hell and the national
culture of u.s science was lost
the thing that produced all this
prosperity and security
and power was lost and then jeff epstein
shows up
and a tiny number of funders maybe fred
cavley
um maybe yuri milner
maybe um who else would be in this
category
peter thiel to an extent howard hughes
would be the largest of these things
which has different grant structures
than the nih
gave people a modicum of risk-taking
ability okay well when jeff epstein
showed up
everybody wanted to take risk
in science and suddenly a charismatic
billionaire says
hey i can make that work for you here's
a hundred thousand dollars go go
research something crazy
well that money was supposed to be
provided
by the federal government under the
terms of the endless frontier compact
between the federal government and the
universities
and the federal government the taxpayers
welched
okay so that's one place to lay the
blame for jeff epstein as that the
the failure of the federal government to
honor
to honor its commitment yeah right so
the universities became psychopathic
it's not like everybody doesn't remember
what we're supposed to be doing to be
moral
but the point was there wasn't enough
money to be moral so it was time
to uh to eye each other as a source of
protein as i like to say
and in that process jeffrey epstein said
hey
come to my world we can do it like we
used to do
so in in part my point is is that almost
none of your colleagues at mit have that
kind of religious commitment to science
that they're willing to go down with
ship
science the galileo galilei
thing became very important to science
because occasionally you just have to
say
look this isn't about me and you i
there isn't enough money in the world to
buy the kind of
legacy i want to leave to this planet
this is one of the great things about
science you know potentially it's worth
dying for
yeah i'm glad you said it
science is one of the things that is
best that's worth dying for
i mean i'm not eager to martyr myself
but i've certainly risked my health my
fortune
you know i've destroyed myself
economically over science
and um
and my my my need to oppose these sons
of [ __ ]
in chaired professorships who are
destroying our system along with
everyone else
you